grazie velocissima questo nuovo video
sono pari j
e oggi sono tanti su quel giochino un po
birichino chiamato giocasse allora ho
notato con piacere che qualcuno ha
creato una mappa chiamata fa vigenti
sfido proviamo perché una sfida
suggerissero non l'ho mai avuta quindi
il goal non so dove mi sta sfidando
portato lui sa che io faccio schifo ma
mi posso muovere almeno a senza muovermi
proprio allora va beh senza muovermi e
se è impossibile però proviamoci
raccolgo sempre sfide alla fondazione a
universitaria al caro il primo e va bene
fin qua allora museo il nacional de arte
al roma i miei
credo che sia romani a giudicare dalle
bandiere anche questo punto ma non so
dove
caro libri quindi alla romania sicuro
bucarest vediamo se riesco a trovare
qualcosa con la piazza università e
spetta attenzione c'è una rotonda qua
forse ho trovata la camicia subito
pazzesco sotto la sud
eccolo qua aspetta università qua c'è un
parco attenzione museo nazionale art a
causa del no ragazzi museo nazionalista
aspetta di arte quello di arte coi arte
eccolo qua museo nazionale d'arte eccolo
qua perfetto perfetto perfetto quindi
quindi quindi di fronte c'è la la la la
la la statua eccola qua calva esatto
esatto quindi qua ho qua qua più verso
dentro verso dentro quindi sono tipo qui
signori signori mamma mia mamma ma che
giocatore è
marco il giocatore so i romani altra
incredibile è la prima classe ha portato
a casa nostra senza muovermi tra o forse
italiane di fiducia abbiamo trattoria
pizzeria bella sofia e va bene
max sushi questo non so allora almeno al
posto devo ricordarmi dove parto però
previsto un casino ma lei messi che ha
fatto stamapa se sta volando subito mare
e sì a caso io lo stai rovinando oppure
c'è un criterio si protegge arcaplanet
facevo compratore cose per sanno quando
l'ho preso l'ho portato a casa la prima
volta no ed è andava in giro con samb in
braccio e la gente gli chiedevo scusa ti
ho un cane cosa compro il cane che non
so come si vive con un cane e la gente
che carino sì ma qualcosa contro aiuto
comunque a eccolo qua città di sancita
di san giuliano milanese san giuliano
milanese proprio lui proprio lui e siamo
in via
siamo in via cazzo ne so io siamo in via
charlie c'è l'unico posto al mondo san
giovanni milanese dove non ci sono le
vie sui muri va bene eccola qua no ecco
qua no sono le vie allora e si estende
vicino all'area aperta dove c'è un
accordo vece una rotonda e san giuliano
via tanto lo so dove sangiuliano milano
vi erano idea di dove sia santuri al
milanese prima cosa san giuliano
milanese paio che cazzo ne so scusi san
giuliano milanese subito trovate tratto
eccola qua la ruota perfetto della
rotonda qui non mi ricordo la partita di
preciso aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
eravamo partiti qua più o meno qua forse
un po più avanti
poste italiane sta qua
mamma mia mamma mia mamma mia che
giocatore che giocatore incredibile
porca vacca questa il mosca questa non
conosco san giuliano milanese ma mosca
ragazzi
mosca mosca mosca milanese è sì però
vabbè scoprire qua preciso non posso
essere ha senso
ovviamente siamo al cremlino ora gas o
problemi non so dove sia il cremlino
certo profetici
scrivilo grosso come una casa amica il
posto più l'interesse di tutta la loro
delle mosche se non lo scrivo non va
bene
lo sappiamo allora il cremino sta qua
non so ragazzi secondo siamo qua però
non ci metto la mano sul fuoco infatti
l'albero a 386 metri per me va già bene
ok sono orgoglio per a 4 su 5 e siamo
raga tensione università questa non mi
posso muovere una prova mai ambasciata
italiana della repubblica moldava
moldavia
quindi siamo tutt europa comunque alla
monta via casa moldave sauron srl santo
iddio sauron srl la voglio vedere chami
ma c'è sauron c'è proprio sauron con
l'unical monte fato dietro è l'anello di
frodo baggins
non ho non so se sia vedo tante
università tema non quella giusta modo
rasset university e potrebbe essere
questa l'ambasciata italiana a 26 casa
della pizza
questa e l'ambasciata italiana non lo so
ragazzi vediamo
potrebbe essere questo non lo so ma
nascerà una parola vero nel male è
andata benissimo dalla gara vicinissima
che culo nel male è andata benissimo
parma parma 2001 proprio parma vicino
all'antica solo merian rastrelli
prefettura eccola qua ok strada petrarca
con coincide esatto esatto
quindi qui qua c'è aspetta però sta qua
qua proprio lui proprio lui ragazzi five
su file c'era veramente fatta una
precisione ragazzi al millimetro un
altro podio c'è veramente che tutte joe
passetto ragazzi ciao
signori è proprio lui mamma mia quando
c'è la sfida di mezzo io non so cazzi e
comunque questa cosa competitivi city
streets che cacchio 25 picca city nei
warm up cerri e dragic checkpoint ok non
capito niente cioe una nuova da rita
bellissimo brano questa prima di
chiudere ragazzi perché secondo me
potrebbe avere senso for free you one
lescaut e tipo un batterio ial 248
player stanno competendo di tu ami che
mi sono un po troppo ragazzi siano un
aiuto e cremlino queste e in russia
siamo comunque le righe russia e non ho
capito questa roba bratislava slovacchia
no in russia siamo
sono le modalità di gioco che non
capisco questo devo fare lo schiaccia
gas
ok e quindi ha quindi avanziamo dice poi
dice poi far vedere chi viene eliminato
pian piano non capito non ho capito un
cazzo di st modalità però va bene dovete
spiegarmi cosa devo fare via crace mente
cemento viagra per potrebbe essere in
bolivia comunque america del sud dove io
sono skillato pari a zero quindi ottimo
merda voli sparato a cazzo di un ailes
ace di rak 6
minchia tre posti questo non mi sa tanto
di california dove california preciso e
non sono mai stato qua però non sono
stato sempre scopriamo a huston toronto
va fango la sorda come no
[Musica]
no